y vimos en el último vídeo que si
definimos la entalpía h como como lines
la energía interna del sistema más la
presión por el volumen también del
sistema y esto es casi una definición
arbitraria pero sabemos que es una
variable de estado válida no importa que
hagamos en términos de cómo llegamos a
cierto punto siempre va a ser el mismo
verdad porque es la suma de variables de
estado pero esto es bastante útil en
bueno vimos en el último vídeo que si
suponemos la presión constante que es
una gran suposición pero hay grandes
razones para proponerlo por ejemplo en
algunas reacciones químicas si estamos
sentados en la playa con nuestros vasos
de precipitados a una temperatura y
presión estándar que no está ocurriendo
entonces podemos suponer que la presión
es es constante y vimos que el cambio
lento en la intel pía se convierte en el
calor agregado al sistema ok en el calor
agregada al sistema a esa presión
constante ok
esta vez para escribir o proponer que
estamos suponiendo que estamos
que estamos suponiendo que la presión es
constante ahora como usamos estos
conceptos de una forma útil digamos que
tengo no sé carbón en su forma elemental
como grafito y que agrego eso digamos
que tengo esa molécula o ese molde
carbón y le agregó dos moléculas o dos
moles de hidrógeno gaseoso si tenemos un
montón de hidrógeno gaseoso ok en su
estado gaseoso digamos en un globo no sé
que van a van a estar atados de esta
forma de atómica verdad cuando están en
forma gaseosa y si los hago reaccionar
voy a producir un molde metano un molde
metano ch4 pero no sólo eso también voy
a producir algo de calor voy a producir
digamos de forma redondeada voy a
producir 74 kilos jules de calor 74
kilos jules de calor y cuando produzco
esa mole ese molde de metano ok
cuando produzco ese único mol
así que qué está ocurriendo aquí primero
que nada cuánto calor está siendo
agregado al sistema estamos suponiendo
que esté calor sólo se libera del
sistema no este no es un proceso a
diabético no es aislado el sistema de
nada simplemente se libera se va se
libera así que mi pregunta es cuánto
digo ya saben empezamos con este
contenedor digamos podríamos podríamos
poner que está a una presión fija y que
a lo mejor tengo un montón de ok digamos
en gris tengo un montón de de carbón
sólido ahí tirado en el vasito y digamos
en algún tipo de polvo y aquí tengo gas
de hidrógeno entonces cada uno de esos
amarillos es hidrógeno no pero bueno
vamos a obtener un montón de gas metano
en es de esta forma si los ponemos a
reaccionar ok en este en este mismo
vamos a hacerlo en verde ahora tenemos
un montón de gas metano y libero 74
kilos jules 74 kilos jules así que
cuánto calor fue agregado al sistema
bueno en realidad liberamos calor
liberamos 74 kilos así que el calor
agregado al sistema es en realidad menos
74 es decir en vez de ir hacia adentro
va hacia afuera
ok si preguntamos por el calor
agregado en realidad es negativo porque
fue liberado es pero se aclaró muy bien
eso y les acaba de mostrar que eso es
exactamente lo mismo que el cambio en la
entalpía
aunque este es el cambio en la antártida
así que como podemos pensar acerca de
esto que es lenta el pia de este sistema
relativo a este bueno eso va a ser más
bajo verdad porque si tomamos dental
pedacito si tomamos el cambio en la
entropía nuestro nuestro entalpía final
- la entalpía inicial del sistema vamos
a obtener un número negativo que son
menos 74 kilos así que esto tiene que
ser mucho menor que esto otro ok por 74
kilos jules así que la entropía final es
menor que lenta al pie inicial y es de
la diferencia es de 74 kilos jules ok
vamos a dibujar por ejemplo si este es
un eje digamos no sé a lo mejor es el
tiempo ok en ese eje y acá arriba vamos
a graficar por ejemplo la entropía vamos
a ponerle entalpía entonces si la
reacción empieza a esta en tal pie
inicial
ok ese es nuestro estado inicial de aquí
ok el que está en el contenedor amarillo
por ejemplo vamos a dejarle el color
amarillo empezamos ahí y después no se
lo agitamos lo podríamos dejarlo ahí a
la intemperie que reacciona quien sabe
pero terminamos en una en tal vía final
digamos que llegamos a esta instancia
final justo aquí después de la reacción
que ha ocurrido porque esta es la
entropía final así que como podemos ver
hemos caído en los niveles de entropía
lo que es interesante aquí es no es cuál
es el valor absoluto del entalpía aquí
sino sino aquí aquí aquí lo interesante
es que tenemos un cambio en la entropía
ok y podríamos pensar en que tanto calor
ha perdido o ganado este sistema y dado
que hay menos calor ok entonces hemos
liberado energía y ya sabemos que hasta
cierto grado
es lo que dijimos en el inicio verdad y
la palabra para cuando esto ocurre
cuando esto ocurre es que es exotérmica
ahora si queremos ir en el sentido
contrario si por ejemplo queremos ir de
metano y liberar en carbón e hidrógeno
es decir separarlo entonces tendríamos
que agregar ese calor para regresar la
reacción verdad ok entonces tendríamos
una un camión en tal vía positiva y
entonces tendríamos una reacción en dos
térmicas y una reacción necesita energía
es en dos térmicas si la libera es
exotérmica ahora podría estarse
preguntando bueno de dónde viene toda
esa energía así que sí sí empecé en un
altar y aquí en la amarilla de esta
definición rara y llegué a la verde y si
vemos dental piar con la presión
constante digamos que el volumen no ha
cambiado mucho por ejemplo para fines
prácticos no así que realmente la mayor
parte del cambio fue en la energía
interna así que si hay una gran energía
interna y luego baja ok entonces eso
está causando que que haya una caída en
la entropía ok ese cambio en la energía
interna está realmente siendo porque se
convierte la energía potencial en calor
que se libera así que ese calor se
libera en forma de
74 kilos jules en forma de calor ahora
todo lo que esto hace es darnos un una
una base para saber cuánto cuánto calor
un producto genera o cuánto o predecir
qué tanto calor necesita ser absorbido o
incluso liberado por distintas
reacciones así que aquí voy a tocar otra
noción la noción de el calor de
formación o que también se le conoce
como entalpía de formación o el cambio
en lenta vía de formación ok
así que el cambio en la entropía de
formación que generalmente está dado a
temperatura y presión y volumen o más
bien presión y temperatura este estándar
digamos que es esto esto va a ser cuál
es el cambio en la entropía que debe
ocurrir para que una molécula se
convierte en otra así que por ejemplo
para el metano ok por ejemplo para el
metano y si queremos descubrir cuál es
el calor su calor de formación decimos
mira por cómo formamos el metano de sus
formas elementales cuál es la delta h
esta reacción y hemos aprendido ya que
la delta h de esta reacción era menos 74
kilos jules que significa que existen
formas metano de sus de sus elementos
digamos digamos de sus bloques
constructivos vas a liberar 74 kilos de
energía y esto es una reacción
exotérmica victo y esto es porque libera
este calor teníamos este metano ok que
es está en un estado bajo de energía o
más bajo de energía que estos dos
originales y debido a eso es más estable
digamos una forma de pensarlo es que si
tienes a un tipo y luego tienes una
montaña aquí ok y acá en la cima tienes
una pelota ya sabes este no es una
directa analogía pero pero es una
analogía para la energía potencial si
está en un estado más bajo tiende a
estar más estable por ejemplo si está
hasta arriba pues es más inestable de
que se caigan
entonces si tienes un montón de metano
el hecho es que tienes una energía
negativa un calor negativo digamos eso
significa que se está liberando en
ok ok es una es una un cambio en la
entropía deformación negativo eso me
dice que el metano es más estable en
relación a sus compuestos a sus
componentes más bien no tienes que
memorizarlo simplemente aquí ya lo he
copiado de una tabla que encontré en
inglés de la wikipedia aquí la tengo
déjenme ver la ok está la de la copia
directamente de la wikipedia solo que
está en inglés y esto nos da la la
formación de el calor de formación
estándar y si vemos por ejemplo aquí
está el aquí tenemos el metano justo
aquí ok con el que estamos trabajando
esencialmente nos están diciendo la
delta h de esta reacción que forma
metano ok ahí nos están diciendo en este
punto de la tabla por ejemplo nos está
diciendo que si empezamos con cierto
carbón en su estado sólido más dos moles
de hidrógeno gaseoso formamos un molde
metano ok y cuando tomamos lenta al pie
de aquí menos la d
los reactivos tenemos un cambio en la
entropía de formación de esta reacción
que a temperatura y presión estándar es
menos 74 kilos jules más o menos por mol
y esto todo esto está por mol verdad ok
aquí es para formar un molde metano si
formamos más moles bueno simplemente
habrá que acomodar los números pero
bueno pues vamos a seguir utilizando
esta tabla en los siguientes vídeos si
vemos por ejemplo aquí el oxígeno mono
atómico tiene un 1
un calor un calor de formación estándar
de positivo verdad que significa que
necesita energía para formarse es decir
sí sí tenemos esta reacción que vamos a
escribir así la mitad o la mitad de un
molde oxígeno gaseoso se convierte en en
un en un molde de un molde oxígeno en su
estado gaseoso mono atómico ok eso nos
dice que este estado este estado tiene
más potencial que este otro y para tener
que llegar a esa reacción tenemos que
agregar la energía tenemos que meter la
energía y de hecho aquí hay que
agregarle 249 jules y tú podrías decir
esto no tiene mucho sentido el oxígeno
es oxígeno porque necesito calor de
formación para el oxígeno lo que tenemos
aquí es suelen su forma elemental así
que el oxígeno cuando tienes un montón
de oxígeno digamos por ahí en el
ambiente o en el aire ok o por ejemplo
hidrógeno
nitrógeno todos estos son gaseosos y por
eso son atómicos el carbón por ejemplo
que es en su forma sólida como grafito
solo es es es mono atómico así que el
calor de formación es relativo a la
forma en que lo encuentras en su versión
pura no necesariamente en su forma
atómica aunque algunas veces coinciden
ahora en el próximo vídeo vamos a
utilizar esta tabla que es bastante útil
sólo la lo copié y la pegué de wikipedia
para resolver algunos problemas en el
olvido vamos a hablar de más del calor
de formación en los próximos vídeos y
vamos a seguir usando la tabla que nos
da el calor estándar de formación para
ciertas reacciones y determinar si es
exotérmica wendo térmica